wenn ihr im deutschen ausdrücken wollte
ihr euch fühlt dann ist euch vielleicht
schon mal folgender fehler passiert ich
bin langweilig ich will geld ja ja ich
bin interessant viele leute die anfangen
deutsch zu lernen fragen sich warum es
in diesen sätzen einen fehler gibt
tatsächlich drückt man viele gefühle im
deutschen mit einem dativ aus man sagt
mir ist kalt und nicht ich bin kalt
warum macht man das im deutschen
unterscheidet man tatsächlich zwischen
dem auslöser eines gefühls und dem
empfänger eines gefühls ich selber bin
nicht kalt die temperatur ist kalt der
kühlschrank ist kalt das wetter ist kalt
und ich empfange diese kälte
ich sage im deutschen mir ist kalt to me
dit is called würde man wörtlich
übersetzen und in mit diesem ganzen
problem dass man viele gefühle im
deutschen mit dem dativ ausdrückt gibt
es viele häufige fehler
hier haben wir die fünf häufigsten
fehler für euch zusammengefasst
ich bin langweilig
mir ist langweilig diese verwechslung
klingt im deutschen sogar richtig lustig
denn tatsächlich kein eine person sowohl
der auslöser als auch der empfänger von
langweile seien im englischen
unterscheidet man zwischen ein board und
ein boring ihr wollt wahrscheinlich
nicht sagen dass ihr langweilig seid
also verwendet den dativ mir ist
langweilig ich bin heiß
mehr ist heißt auch dieses
missverständnis klingt für viele
deutsche lustig denn wenn eine person
heiß ist ist das gleichzeitig ein
anderes wort für attraktiv francisco
wollte wahrscheinlich nicht sagen dass
er sich selbst für sehr attraktiv hält
sondern er wollte sagen mir ist heiß er
wollte über die temperatur sprechen ja
ich bin interessant
ich bin interessiert janisch ist
sicherlich ein interessanter mensch wenn
man im deutschen jedoch sagen will dass
man etwas interessiert ist dann sagt man
das interessiert mich oder ich bin
interessiert
im englischen gibt es sogar die gleiche
unterscheidung man kann sagen ein
interested oder einem interesting zwei
verschiedene bedeutungen und so ist es
im deutschen auch interessant und
interessiert ich bin schlecht
mir ist schlecht wenn du sagst ich bin
schlecht dann bedeutet das dass du ein
schlechter mensch bist wahrscheinlich
möchtest du sagen dass du dich schlecht
fühlst auch hier musst du wieder den
dativ benutzen
mir ist schlecht heißt du fühlst dich
schlecht
ich will geld mehr ist kalt und das
letzte beispiel haben besprochen wenn
francisco friert dann sagt er mir ist
kalt
denn die kälte kommt von hausen und
franziskus spürt diese kälte er benutzt
also den daten
mir ist kalt das weiß für diese woche
und wenn ihr lust habt könnt ihr jetzt
noch ein vokabular verbessern und das
geht mit unserer apps suite lingen die
könnt ihr mal ausprobieren dort haben
wir unter anderem ein vokabeltrainer
gebaut darin gibt es die 4500
wichtigsten deutschen wörter und ihr
könnt die übungen und zwar mit
verschiedenen übungen aussprache
trainings und auch im kontext von setzen
könnt ihr die einzelnen vokabeln lernen
probiert das mal aus wir freuen uns auf
euer feedback und ja ich hoffe wir sehen
uns am sonntag wieder zu unserem
nächsten video und bis bald
[Musik]
[Gelächter]